what's with the jeans you know I have a
Jean dilemma maybe you can help me with
oh sure I'm serious I have a Jean
problem okay no my post-birth body I'm a
little fatter than I've been in the past
and I buy regular people jeans but I'm
kind of like in this Jean dilemma or
like the ones I bought are too big but
then when I go a size down it's too
tight hmm so what do I do
I've been there a lot I've been there
for years like I'm in-between sizes so
what pair of jeans do I wear in the
meantime always there I know exactly
what you're talking about cuz one pair
it's too high and tight if I wear the
lower size and then they're low and
loose if I wear the the size about I
can't do the low and loose I would
rather go a little snug what I try to do
is then you get something a little tight
it's a little higher than you normally
wear it so we don't tighter and you just
suffer through some tight hours right
and then it kind of loosens later in the
day but it just loosens ever so slightly
it feels like it's almost made for you
at that point right then you wear it for
a few days and it'll fit perfectly
day after day you have to power through
those really high and tight
oh there would you not share that with
everybody but I started to feel bad for
them
but the thing is yeah you got to be
ready for some uncomfortable times yeah
but what happens is eventually it'll be
perfect okay so I've actually I can keep
on them they'll eventually get loose
loose sagging and then I have to go
another size down yeah the thing is is
that you just can't sit down and you're
high in tight jeans and you can't eat as
long as I don't sit or eat the beans
feel the kind of feel nice when they're
high and tight when we're talking about
this like Sunday's you like your jeans
extra high and tight some days I don't
yeah I mean pretty much I like them high
and tight you know all the time nobody
can have their jeans high and tight all
the time it's it's pretty it's pretty
much a lot it's
yes oh if I could put a call out there
guys any ladies out there know of any
really good genes for when you're kind
of still fat post part of me some what
are some good genes to make a lady look
a little skinnier and it was a belly
right now I go to the gap but I feel
like there's a brand up there I'm not
aware of that I should be checking out
they're gonna respond yeah let me know
girls if you've had a baby and I don't
want to wear maternity jeans anymore
it's too depressing nah Baba television
I need normal people jeans just like fat
people James